hello youtube just Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here and today I have
a one question for you against v4 I am
getting tired of playing passively such
as playing French defense a6 or
cariocans with c6 by giving up the
center and only stage and then hitting
back or are you getting tired of playing
Aoife where white can play all sorts of
gamete such as Kings gambit or the
Danish gambit or the Gordian gambit also
you may be fed up by studying on lots
and lots of theory of Sicilian and still
does not come out as an attacking
opening well when I start playing chess
I was always wondering that is there any
other other systems apart from ePHI and
c5 which are equally very good and which
sees the innocent initiative from the
white at only stages and most important
thing is can I get a center as a black
and after going through so many openings
I was very disappointed and I thought
maybe there isn't any but when I came to
know about the Colorado gambit I was
very very excited and the first thing is
this gambit is very very aggressive a
system against the white efore and it's
like it achieves everything like it sees
the initiative from the white it's all
so many lines it sees the center and
black has a very free piece play and in
some lines you get a vigorous attack
against the white castle's shot if the
white castle's shot so all in all it's a
complete package against efore and the
big bonus is I have played up till now
probably more than hundred games and
many opponents I found it
they are very confused against this
gambit they completely don't know how to
react and somehow they fall into some of
the nice traps of this gambit or they
completely lost positionally so join
with me today for this wonderful gambit
and learn about the tricks and traps
exist in this line so let's start the
opening so white place efore
Here I am recommending a move which is
knight c6 which is known as Williams of
which defense what it does is basically
it avoids any nasty Oh like gambit
opening such as f4 which is Kings gambit
or d4 which is Dennis gambit and it's
kind of inviting why to go again go back
to night f3 line where this gambit will
not affect anything to the black so here
there are two good moves from the white
side white can play this move d4 well in
this case you should I recommend you
should go through the theory section of
news of each defense where I think I
personally think the good move is ePHI
and you should know what if what happens
if wide take that pole or moves further
or also goes go back to the main line of
squash so that you need to prepare if
you are preparing about this gambit II
anyways that is a completely different
chapter and if I get a time I will cover
those as well
right now let's stick to the main line
which is 9 of 3 so it's kind of wide
which like you know is hoping that black
play Aoife and goes back again to the
line which probably he has prepared for
example a modern Italian game or the
role of s
everything will be fine for white but
here comes the big surprise and the
surprise is f5 and to be honest with you
many times when I play specially in
blitz people here stuck for 10 to 15
seconds and they try to find out Oh what
exactly going on and what I will do in
this video is first we will have a look
what is what is most likely a general
response of the from the white side that
if any kind of gambit occurred which the
opponent does not know then he tried to
stay away from it rather than accepting
and what we will do here is first we
will go through the most dangerous way
to decline the gambit step by step to
the least and then we'll finally have a
look what happens if white accepts the
Gabby so let's go to the most aggressive
response from the wide by declining the
gambit and the first move is ePHI so
pushing by and white is hoping that he
has a more space than black because Fi
of course weakening the king of the
black and white can grab some space on
the center and now here I recommend you
go d6 so now again attacking the put
that pawn and now here there are two
lines first line which is very
aggressive are white
he tried to hold on to that ball and by
playing this move Bishop defy and here
there's a things come there comes the
first strap in this line and please
remember this moves because I guarantee
you somebody will going to fall for that
and probably I have one around 10 to 15
games like this so line goes like this
so of course black will take that pole
and white will be jolly delight because
not only the knight can regain that pole
but now to pc's attacking that poor ole
light right so why do you be more than
happy but here comes the shock so queen
defy attacking night as well as bishop
and wide maybe thought oh flag has
fallen into one of the cheap trap and he
will go for this line so Bishop takes
now of course we need to capture
recapture with the pole and now comes
this track and this is very typical trap
occurs at the beginners level but here
it's outright mistake by white let's see
how so after screen check of course you
need to play g6 and after Knight
captures here comes the first move which
is 9 f6 so gaining a time on a queen
there's only one logical square if we if
the Queen moves from the h-file then the
knight drops so Queen has to stay on the
edge file so Queen goes back to s4 and
now can you spot a very nice combination
or nice way to start
okay I'm going for it right now so the
correct move is queen cross g2 and now
you can see that two pieces are hanging
the rook is hanging as well as the night
and if white is foolish enough to take
the rook otherwise it will lost piece
for nothing then Queen takes rook King
goes to e to and now instead of grabbing
that bishop in the corner which is this
one there is a stronger more than that
and please note this move if you are
going to play this line and that move is
f4 and now you can see that bishop is
almost hanging now so white needs to
defend that bishop and there is only one
move which is Knight c3 which at least
defending that bishop but now comes the
mating attack which is and please
remember this line so now now called the
mating attack which you should remember
bishop chat so now King has only one
square which is king d3 now Queen F in
track King has again has only one
possibility which is king d4 now comes
rope check again one square
King c4 so he can see fine and now after
ePHI king test 6 key take c6 and queen
a6 only move left for the White King is
to take that pole afterwards
it leads to mate in one so Queen b6 is a
checkmate
so this is a one of one of the very good
trap in this lion so you should remember
this trap
and see how the right key was dancing
around and we have enjoy to meet him
okay so that was a first nice cute rap
in this line if Y become greedy and play
bit of beef I now you should know what
to do if white except the point so in
the second case let's consider white
taking on this bone so he crossed e6 and
now we should capture by the C pawn and
now again there are two lines so if
let's say white is playing very
passively for example [ __ ] let's take
this line which is Bishop b2 ePHI and
after castle line up six now indeed
there is a threat of if efore so why
needs to stop that
so after d3 we have this move
d4 d5 and now you can see or three pawn
are covering the center and how often
you get this kind of structure against
white and spinel is 3/4 in fact I don't
remember much openings which you give
you that much advantage see how much
centers we are covering and not only
that where simple planning is Bishop is
coming to d6 and then we cancel and then
we have automatic King side attack
starting with f5 probably I don't know
but there are many ways you can do it
right so it's almost you are equal or
more than equal at this point so that is
one of the line if white plays very very
passively so let's see a line where
white place aggressively so white plays
Knight c3 and after our Aoife white
plate okay instead of d4 if y is foolish
enough to play Bishop c4 which looks
like a logical move because the F file
has been open so it's very logical to
play Bishop c4
but after Aoife fo that poro light does
not have any good squares so light has
to go back and white is next sorry black
is next is playing Knight f6 and bd5 and
like black is almost more than equal
here are probably higher so of course
this option for is is not a good move so
the correct move is the d4 and after d4
that should play Knight f6 you need to
hurry or push up I pause right now we
need to carry on the development so
after Knight f6 the sample line goes
like this so white will play d5 and
after Knight be for this is one of my
game which I play on internet it when
told like that
so after night before he give me a check
my want to give me a check so I block
with the bishop and after Bishop takes
Queen takes
a three by night nicely drop bags to a
six where it can it can comes to either
c5 or c7 depending on the scenario so
for example in this game
my opponent Castle and after Bishop e7
he come out with the Knight g4 which at
first sight looks that he six square is
very very very very very much on the car
with the night but I can nicely cover
that square again by with my knight
Knight to c7 and after Queen d3 castle I
there's long game happen which are
initially won but you can see black has
those two poles upon e Phi n f5 which
covering the whole center and that is
more than equal here at this stage black
then in a moment I can kick that night
away and then my pawns are only so see
again black is covering the center and
again this opening turns out very well
here okay moving on so that was all
about the ePHI push
okay if uh if there are other ways where
white does not need to push that pole
white can go for the second line which
is stars like this so Knight to c3 and
of course white is developing but he has
seized the center and this is one of the
very good line where black get a good
center over out of it so let's see how
the black achieved is so after F cross C
night cross C we play d4 and most
logical square for the knight is Knight
g3 and after ePHI again we have the
center and a sample line can be goes
like this
so after Bishop b5 we play Bishop g4 and
after h3 we simply lop off that night
and after Queen takes we play Knight f6
and if you open and feeling aggressive
he might try this move Knight h4 night
h5 but after very simple move Queen d6
Knight takes pawn takes and Queen h5
check looks like we are disturbing the
castle in but there is no issues because
black and simply play Queen d7 and in
next moves the root can come out to be 8
and King goes back again to see it and
he tends to move as artificial castle
and look at the center we have nice free
pawn Center where why does not have any
center and
we have almost a very good game from
here so that is against Knight c3 now
there is another line where right
completely gambit is a point which
starts like this so Bishop to c4 that's
the line but here I think this is the
worst scenario of the scenario for the
white side because this is very simple
to play as a black because we have a
very simple reply of course II now if
Knight g5 I don't believe this because
after defy our black is almost very well
placed here so the main line goes like
this so Bishop takes g8 here we will
continue like this so across f3 and
after Bishop b5 f cross G 2 and after
Bishop cross G 2 G 6 have a look our
planning is very simple Bishop g7
castling on the Kings side and we can
seize the central by playing Eve I the
e5 or D fire depending on the situation
and the main drawback for the white is
see those pawns H 2 and F 2 they are
very very weak and that can be a big
asset force in even in the endgame so ah
see the opening it's tunnels its tunnels
very very well and if your opponent is
refuting this gambit we should be very
happy because we're getting a very very
good initiative as well as the big
center so finally let's see what happens
if
after this moves right except the gambit
so equals fi well here you should play
d5 so our first priority is to regain
that pawn by capturing with the bishop
now if widest right once you try to hang
on to that phone then he might be feel
he might come under different kind of
tactics so let's say first white is try
to hang on to that pole so by playing
Bishop to d3 well here very simple will
diffuses to play Knight at 6:00 so again
attacking that pawn and if white play is
now light to h4 that comes a very good
tactic so efile so please note or black
white cannot take the denpa sign because
the knight is hanging so where your
obvious response is to quintet to f7 and
after such a boom like Knight to c3 we
have another amazing mu which is g6 and
first side on the first side it looks
like a suicidal because there's I have
Paul and you giving a for a whole space
but there is a big tactics let's say if
white is finishing up take that F cross
g6 then after H cross g6 you can see
that poor Knight is hanging so that is
not possible
and if Queen goes away for example Queen
goes to g4 of course he needs to remain
in contact with the night because Knight
no Knight is hanging so
in this case again there is a very good
one good move I give you a few seconds
can you spot amazing move over here okay
the good know is this move g5 and now
look at that poor Knight it has only one
square which is f3 and after the night
goes back to s3 we have pi e 4 and the
two pieces are hanging and in one of my
game my opponent took this spawn by
Bishop he thought that he is gaining a
two-pole from the bishop but to his
horror after this move he he probably
think the he probably realized the
situation is getting worst and the
correct move over here is h4 and look at
now forget about the bishop now queen is
look like it's a trap and let's say if
the Queen goes over here then we have
more time on the Queen well by playing
Bishop to d6 and after Queen only square
which is s3 we take this Bishop and
again we are looming the threads like g4
so why does not have any time to capture
on that Ebola and it's a disgusting
position for the white so my black will
have all kind of ones
okay so that was first option when white
is trying to hang on to that pawn with
Bishop d3 let's took the second option
where it hang on to the pawn another way
so night to h4 straight away intending
queen h5 check in this case we are
playing again night at six and after
Queen h4 queen s file check now we play
g6 and this amazingly turns out very
well for Brack it's a sacrifice its upon
sacrifices so after F cross G H cross G
and here there are again two options if
Knight cross g6 then we have this move
Bishop to g4 and after let's say if
Queen goes to G Phi then we have this
one look or to g8 and it's spinning the
night and our next agenda is to Queen to
d6 which will attack that night and
castling on the Queen side and black has
very good initiative over here if the
Queen goes to h4 in this case we have
another good move which is Queen to d6
and now that Knight is hanging and the
check is looming so for example if your
opponent is foolish enough to take the
rock in the collar then that leads to
make so
this is one of the good travel for
Colorado gambit and let's see if you
open on take here with the Queen
so queen cross g6 now again Knight comes
back to like Knight comes to f7 and now
you see that night is hanging so white
has to forcefully play either g6 or if
he does not want to play that
sorry g3 then he has to retrieve the
knight to f3 well here we'll start with
the gaining initiative against the Queen
so Luke goes to at 6 Queen goes back and
now Bishop to a5 and one of the game
from here one of my own game
struggles from here like that so Bishop
after Bishop to fi my opponent play d4 I
played again the rook g6 gaining time on
clean so Queen goes 2-4 and after Queen
to d7 now you see that few threads over
here so if the knight has been allowed
to be 4 then c2 is ready and if the
bishop nose to the b4 then the spawn is
hanging
so by considering all this my opponent
play Bishop III but then I simply cancel
on the Queen side and after the knight
III I play d6 and after he played night
to be Phi I played Bishop to d7 and I
think there's only one move and he
played the Queen to f4 which after the
bishop sorry rook to g4 he song is
simply realized that he has a lost
position
anyways if the Queen does not trap like
that white a black has a very simple
plan which put the rooks are covering H
and G file as I mentioned by the arrows
like this group goes over here and this
rook is already on the G file and then
if the White Castle on the somehow
managed to castle on the King side then
we have a furious attack on this H and G
pawns and you can see that there is a
big initiative for the black over here
and I would if anybody would like to be
as a black in this position okay so that
is about
let's say hanging onto that pole now in
Moscow scenario especially in the Tuda
winds why it will know all this and
probably he we go through more
positional play for example playing such
move like d4 well here we should of
course regain our pond so bishop cross
f5 and considering all the scenario I
will choose a most aggressive one from
the white side so the most aggressive
one which starts like this so Bishop
goes to the b5 and now it's starting to
[ __ ] over poles so we should first of
all play a six and in one of my game
my opponent play the most aggressive
line which is of course the main line in
this Colorado gambit which is nice to
Knight to e5 and here I play Knight to
e7 and which is intending to play a six
and drive over that Bishop so my upon
decide to do not give me that that much
amount of time so he first of all gave
me this check and after g6 the Queen
goes back to e to a nicely defending the
knight so here as a net to get an
advantage there is only one move for the
black and that is Bishop to g7 again
hitting that night and after more such
as
okay in the game my opponent player bg5
this will happen but we should see what
happens if white tries to be greedy and
he plays moves such as
g4 where g4 does not turns out with a
big deal because after the bishop goes
to e4 and if vital he can trap the
bishop by playing f3 here comes the big
surprise which is can you spot it yep
it's a castle and now if white is
foolish enough to care capture that
bishop now comes the shock so knight
cross d4 and now you can see the two
pieces are hanging as well as the knight
and black will have a wonderful position
probe from over here okay
so my opponent probably knows all this
and he played Bishop g5 so you can see
now the two bishops are pinning those
tights but there is a good move here for
the black side and virtues which is
Queen to d6 which is right now
supporting that night and and also
unpinning from one of the bishop and in
one of my game
my opponent play Bishop takes Knight and
after King takes take this Bishop it
took another night so I regain by the
pawn
and Gaines continues like this so he
played f4 supporting that night but
after through p8 and c3 you can see my
roots at my my 'true can go anywhere on
the back rack and my then king can slot
back into the g8 square and most
important factor is white sari black has
a bishop pad and sooner or later the
game will be open and that will give an
advantage to the black so I hope you
enjoy all this lines and especially for
me this turn turns out very well and I
hope by considering all these lines even
for you this will turn out very well
before we leaving I like to thank you FM
velu which in fact the show me this line
I have learned this line from his one of
his video and I have included some of
his variation and some of my bye-bye
with experience by playing with this
line and with the help of Fitz so I wish
you best of luck to play this line and
you will see how enjoying experience you
will have by playing this line I thank
you thank you so much for watching my
video please feel free to comment on my
video and I will talk to you soon bye